by joining us now he's got like nine
jobs Ross Tucker football podcast CBS
ESPN NBC Westwood one Ross Tucker
football analyst and former NFL lineman
joining the show Ross how are you Denny
brother good one of my jobs used to be a
fill-in for Dan but I guess not anymore
you know if you could have got up the
turnpike in 45 minutes I just don't see
that happening but we want to get to
something you it's been the topic all
week I'm sure on your football show on
Sirius you've been dealing with this
almost exclusively per loft can you give
Ross the the poll question today on the
NFL roughing the passer rule okay should
the NFL change the rule just asked
officials quietly to call it less or
leave it as is I like the second one
there and that's what I tweeted earlier
this morning I think that's what's going
to happen so do you guys remember the
first two weeks of the preseason when
they called the helmet rule about a
million times everybody was freaking out
and I might even come on with Dan and
said they'll dial it back once the
season comes they actually dialed it
back that week now they said they didn't
change the rule but that they were going
to make sure they weren't including
incidental contact of the helmet and
since then it's barely been called at
all and so I think you'll see something
similar in the sense that they've made
their point now about the roughing the
passer penalties they're trying to
protect those guys they know how
important they are to the business to
the NFL I mean nobody wants to watch a
Niners game for the rest of the year I
mean nobody like nobody liked watching
the Packers and Brett humming without
Aaron Rodgers so I get it they're doing
everything they can to try to keep
quarterbacks as safe as possible for the
business but I think they'll tell the
officials now hey unless it's clear that
the guys putting all his weight on or
really trying to you know Tony Stewart
goose' him like you did the rich can in
that one year don't call it you know we
were talking earlier Ross that is it
fair though that the Packers might have
lost a game because of this rule and
then all of a sudden they're gonna stop
calling it like is there any concern
about competitive balance over the
course of the 16-game season it seems a
little ridiculous
probably not that's probably not fair
but I don't know is it fair that they
Institute the rule because the Packers
quarterbacks the one that got hurt last
year I mean if you want to do that you
could say well Baron Rodgers just threw
the ball away faster and didn't get hurt
against the Vikings then they never
would Institute this rule in the first
place it is by the way unbelievably
ironic isn't it that the Packers and
Clay Matthews have been the one affected
the most by this rule and they really
instituted it because their quarterbacks
the one that got hurt last year as a
result of its kind of kind of crazy you
know I don't want to I hate I hesitate
to throw out the R word here but is
there any way replay helps sort of ease
some of these concerns and make these
calls a little more clear well I I think
that they should it make everything
reviewable seaton I've always said that
the only thing I would say though unlike
pass interference and roughing the
passer I don't think that they would
actually overturn it unless it's really
really blatant that they did it wrong
and remember both Clay Matthews hits the
NFL came out with a video for the
Redskins won it was during the game it
said yep that's legit that's a penalty
don't come to us don't complain that's a
penalty so if in both instances the NFL
said it was correctly called you know
replay review wouldn't help anyway
because they're tell they're saying it's
the right call I'm with you I think
everything should be reviewable look the
coaches only have to challenge it anyway
so I don't really see what the big deal
is but when it comes to like a hold or
this or pass interference unless the
video replay was unbelievably compelling
especially with judgment calls like that
they're not going to overturn Ross
Tucker of the aptly-named Ross Tucker
podcast network joining the Dan Patrick
show if you were starting offensive
lineman down with the Tampa Bay Bucs do
players openly or behind the scenes
lobby for a certain quarterback or not
and what does that ever happen
I think that the the head coach might
privately ask a couple of team leaders
what they think but this to me is a joke
I mean you know they don't ask all the
offensive linemen the one thing
offensive linemen can do is you could
kind of make it known subtly with your
quotes to the paper like we all lost
Fitz we're all behind him all the way
he's an unbelievable job for us like so
without the coach asking you every coach
reads those clips I'm have seen the
coaches they read what the players are
saying about the team about the upcoming
opponent cuz they want to make sure
they're not giving it any away so that
would be your way to kind of make that
clear but they're not going to Jameis
Winston I mean Fitzpatrick is the first
quarterback ever to throw for over four
yards three straight games he had a good
game I mean he had a couple picks I'd
say one and a half of those were really
his fault but I don't know how you
stopped him from being in there I mean
godwyn had two drops and a fumble and if
any one of about seven different things
happened they'd probably win that game I
can't imagine that they would put
Jameson I will say this though guys this
is a very very important game for
Fitzpatrick against the Bears Sunday
because they're coming off a loss if you
plays poorly here then they go into
their bye week and then they probably do
make the change so he needs to play well
otherwise they would make the change
going into the bye week but they're not
going to make the change here I mean I'm
not buying dirt cutters Jedi mind-trick
Fitzpatrick starting on Sunday Ross
Tucker Princeton grad showing his Ivy
League bias there Ross we're debating
before the show is this September swoon
for the Patriots the real thing or is it
just another case of belcheck figuring
out his team I'm gonna say it's just
another case of Belichick scenarios team
until it really happens because I think
three out of the last eight years have
been like this could be real this time
and you're always wrong like saying that
the Patriots in dynasty is over or
saying that it's real or even just
picking the Patriots to lose
that is not a good bet over time you're
gonna lose and be wrong a lot more than
your right and win so I think they'll
figure it out I think they beat the
dolphin just can't imagine the Dolphins
beating them to go up three games in the
AFC East in Foxborough I mean I don't
see that happening I think the Patriots
figure it out this week then they get
Edelman back they probably get Josh
Gordon going just enough that he can
actually take the top off the defense
give them somebody that can draw some
type of double coverage which is really
all they need so that seven boots can't
cover Gronk every play Rus we missed you
today buddy thanks for helping us out
talk to you soon you guys are doing
great it's really weird to see you guys
in the different chairs especially
Fritzie Roz I got one quick question for
you let you go which bandwagon is safer
to jump on Chiefs or Rams Rams defense
is terrible Rams for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]